désolé je me suis le président merci
voilà je vais parler pour mon compte
mais en même temps pour mon groupe vous
allez nous lister les amendements un par
un nous demandait de nous prononcer
fais-moi moi j'ai pas un cerveau comme
ça je vous dis clairement et pour faire
refaire à nouveau se réapproprier la
main et et prendre une position je
dirais fondée rationnel
sur certaines d'entre eux parce que
parce que ce sont les nôtres ça va aller
sur d'autres ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué quoi
voilà donc on est dans une situation
ubuesque
ubuesque je pensais pas un jour en tant
que sénateur vivre des moments comme
celui-là quoi franchement je sais pas si
il y a des Français qui nous regardent
sur Internet ou ailleurs mais c'est tout
ça tout ça n'est pas à l'honneur du
Sénat et du Parlement de manière de
manière générale quoi voilà c'est c'est
vraiment regrettable d'être dans cette
situation quoi
[Musique]